salut aujourd'hui je vous fais un petit
mentale fact rapide sur le détournement
d'attention ses larmes préféré des
magiciens mais la plupart du temps on
pense qu'on est immunisé et que ça ne
marche pas sûr alors que c'est très
compliqué de focaliser son attention sur
plusieurs choses en même temps par
exemple depuis tout à l'heure vous ne
voyez pas que ce coussin se balade un
petit peu partout dans mon dos asie
vérifier
[Musique]
il ya quelques temps volkswagen a sorti
un truc qui s'appelle l'impossible
challenge je les ai contactés pour
savoir si je pouvais récupérer la vidéo
dans ma propre vidéo sans qu'ils fassent
une atteinte aux droits d'auteur et
m'ont dit qu'ils ont fait ce que t'en
veux y a pas de problème je vais donc
m'en servir pour illustrer le propos
mais je vais pas le faire tout seul je
le fais avec mélanie vous ai déjà vu
mélanie plusieurs fois dans la vidéo on
va essayer de voir si à nous deux on
arrive à relever le challenge
je vous explique et puis je vous
changent de place aussi donc il faut qu
on compte le nombre de tours du ballon
plus le nombre de rebond de la balle
plus le nombre de packs fait le mec
les trois en même temps j'ai clairement
pas réussi du coup je me dis si on
divise la tâche en deux est-ce qu'on y
arrive mieux tu vois ce cas de cervoni
arrivent mieux parce qu'on est bien de
cerveau qu on est tous les deux mais les
nuits qui prend quoi toi aussi fais ça
et moi je fais les rebond de la balle et
nombre de parts est prête
on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
note les chiffres parce que j'en ai deux
en tête on va je me suis dit maintenant
tu parles valentin fra combien je valide
vous venez d'échouer avec brio on peut
pas se focaliser sur trois actions aime
tant en vrai t'as vu moi j'en avais deux
j'ai raté les deux ou alors j'ai réussi
les deux et c'est toi qui dit on ne sait
pas on dit c'est pas moi en fait le but
pour eux c'est de mettre en avant les
délais toute l'assistance électronique
en fait de leur nouvelle voiture mais
moi mon but c'est de vous prouver que
l'on peut pas se focaliser comme ça
notre attention un petit peu partout et
depuis quelques années il ya eu des
tests d'attention comme ça qu'on a fait
parce que je peux en faire un sur toi
oui oui elle n'a pas le choix c'est
formidable ce soir incroyable rouleaux
de papier toilette de tests d'attention
est très simple mélanie ce n'est pas non
plus une vidéos sponsorisées par le
papier toilette
euh ben tu vois on a dit la marque pas
ça fait déjà deux marques
bah oui mais moi je lis je sais pour que
deux postes beaucoup de temps et honnête
le but de ce test d'attention c'est que
tu détermine si je la mets dans ma main
droite ou dans ma main gauche
d'accord c'est aussi simple que ça est
ce que tu es prête ou pas combien ou
voilà où nulle part où en fait juste
derrière toi c'est à dire qu'en te
faisant focaliser me regarde juste ici
moi ça me permet d'atteindre un angle
mort qui est juste là et qui me permet
de faire de ce matin est ce que tu peux
leur certifier que tu n'as pas vu les
vrais de partir c'est à dire que notre
attention est focalisée ici on ne prend
plus en compte ce qui se passe à partir
de là donc dans mon mouvement de poignet
je peux faire partir juste ici la
boulette
je vous faire voir maintenant deux
autres vidéos qui sont tout aussi
intéressante et c'est toujours sur
l'attention sélective
là c'est moi qui ai compté avec mélanie
au départ mais là c'est vous qui allez
compter des choses dans cette première
vidéo je vais vous demander de compter
le nombre de passes que se font les
joueurs
les trois joueurs au premier plan du
terrain de basket donc vous comptez le
nombre de passes dans votre esprit
allez-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réponse était 10 alors déjà je sais
pas si vous l'aviez ou pas mais surtout
je me demande si vous aviez vu que
durant la vidéo le panier du terrain de
basket disparaît progressivement et si
vous me croyez pas allez voir ça c'est
une expérience intéressante parce qu'il
ya quelque chose qui est en train de
changer
cela tenait progressivement en temps
réel et comme on est focus sur un compte
on ne le voit pas passer cette vidéo là
elle existe sur une chaîne youtube qui a
quatre autres expériences comme ça donc
je vous invite à aller regarder je
mettrai le lien dans la description là
je vais vous mettre une autre vidéo il
n'y a pas de piège mais c'est un peu
plus compliqué comme l'impossible le
challenge c'est à dire qu'il ya huit ou
neuf joueurs sur un terrain de basket
mais il ya deux ballons et vous devez
compter le nombre de passes collectives
c'est-à-dire que la de vous devez
réussir à ouvrir votre attention pour
compter toutes les passes
en même temps je vous met la vidéo je
vous dis le résultat
[Musique]
à
le résultat a été treize déjà si vous
aviez le bon résultat vous pouvez mettre
un pouce en l'air à la vidéo mais c'est
pas ça le plus important le plus
important c est ce que vous avez vu un
ours faire du moonwalk dans la vidéo
vous assure je pense que là il ya déjà
déjà en commentaires qui sont en train
d'écrire mais moi j'avais vu l'ours
essayer de pas trop spoiler et essayer
de détourner un peu cette phrase pour
qu'on comprenne pas pour que ceux qui
n'étaient pas attentifs se fassent avoir
comme moi je me suis fait avoir la
première fois parce que ça aussi c'est
une vidéo dont je vous mets le lien dans
la description qui a été fait sur plein
d'autres formats avec un gorille avec un
détournement d'attention qui montre
encore une fois les limites de l'être
humain à être multitâche
alors cette vidéo comme on est au début
de la semaine je la voulais plutôt sur
le côté tests un peu ludique mais là ce
qui était intéressant de rajouter avec
l'impossible challenge c'était aussi
notre incapacité de concentration sur
trois éléments en même temps en fait du
coup sûr d'eux parce que j'ai pas mal si
sûr je serais très curieux d'avoir vos
résultats aussi je vais vous mettre un
lien vers leur site parce qu'ils ont eu
la gentillesse d'accepter de me donner
les roches hd leurs vidéos et que je
m'en sers dans la vidéo donc n'hésitez
pas à aller sur leur site à faire le
test s'il vous plaît il ya trois autres
tests et à me donner les résultats dans
les commentaires de ce que vous avez
réussi à faire vous pas je vous mettrai
aussi les murs mais c'était pas fou mais
essayez il ya quatre tests pour ceux qui
se posent la question de quand est-ce
que je vais traiter la collecte des
données de la dernière expérience
mentale
sachez que j'aurai terminé de m'en
occuper en fin de mois en attendant
n'oubliez pas de ne pas être silencieux
pas silencieux vous la communauté active
comme la communauté passive n'hésitez
pas à vous exprimer à l'aide d'un petit
pouce ou d'un commentaire m'a fait
revoir que vous êtes là et moi je vous
donne rendez-vous bientôt et je pense
que ce bientôt ce sera samedi peut-être
avant pour ça cliquez sur la petite
cloche comme ça vous serez
[Musique]
et